protestas inhabituales en dos países con
gobiernos autoritarios donde la
población sale a la calle y se enfrenta
a la represión en Irán y China la gente
demuestra al mismo tiempo su frustración
y su cansancio en el primer caso por la
muerte de más a Minnie símbolo de la
rigidez del código islámico iraní y de
la represión contra las mujeres en China
por la muy estricta política cero covid
de Pink protestas distintas en su
naturaleza los chinos antes de la
cuarentena no eran una sociedad
movilizada podemos decir que era una
sociedad que estaba bastante conforme
con la situación económica y realmente
lo que está sucediendo en China es que
los ciudadanos sean hartado de lo
prolongada de la cuarentena y lo que
ellos quieren es recuperar su estatus
actual
A diferencia de China la muerte de Mini
fue el detonador de un movimiento mucho
más amplio que cuestiona en su totalidad
al sistema político y religioso soy
iraní y en el caso de Irán es el
hartazgo un régimen político que reprime
pero que también a diferencia de China
fracasado económicamente Así que ahí hay
un fracaso generalizado es mucho más
serio lo que está pasando en Irán
probablemente termine en algún cambio
radical no sabemos cuándo y gran nacido
el escenario de varias protestas en los
últimos años el actual movimiento que ya
ha dejado alrededor de 350 muertos y que
ha entrado en su tercer mes no parece
tener fin Próximamente por su parte
china no ha conocido movilizaciones
desde 1989 el régimen de Pink todavía
tiene tiempo de revertir la situación si
logra flexibilizar su política sanitaria
sin embargo si la frustración sigue en
China podríamos asistir a un escenario
inesperado